We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P, no hate today.
Just two heartwarming, wholesome messages
of support.
I wasn't, uh, I'm just calling because I want
to tell you to keep up the good work.
I watched your show and you're one of the
few people that I think actually reports honestly.
Um, so keep it up by all means.
All right.
And another whole semester
I tell you to keep getting into independent
media and streaming it for us so we can know
the truth and the whole world can see it.
Good job.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
All right.
You guys know how much hate we get in the
voicemail.
So just to, uh, to completely wholesome callers
today, no trolling, no antisemitism, no homophobia,
no use of a variety of four letter words,
no grammar mistakes.
It's a beautiful thing.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the tragic death of Kobe
Bryant and we will contextualize it as well,
plus much more.
That's really a huge story.
Over the last 24 hours, we will talk about
other things.
Become a member to get instant access to the
bonus show@joinpacman.com and by becoming
a $5 a month,
a month or greater member at patrion.com/david
Packard, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].